good morning good afternoon and good
evening depending on where you are
joining us from welcome to simpler
welcome to webinar white cloud computing
makes DevOps inevitable my name is
Martin Sufi and your moderator and also
I will be most in the background
helping burn a golden hour trainer for
today's session so that everything goes
smoothly during this session all the
participant will be on the mute mode to
avoid the background noises and now
please go ahead and type a message in
the chatting module just say hi or hello
and let us know that you're here this
will let us know that you are hearing us
and everything is connected properly we
have our trainer who will be conducting
this webinar as why cloud computing
makes devop inevitable and this is as he
said Bernard golden you know the DevOps
in the cloud go hand in hand according
to many experts which means I tease use
of cloud computing may Mac make DevOps
tools inevitable and now in order to I
would like to inform you that in order
to improve our services and refeed back
is essential for us and we request you
all to please take up the survey and
provide feedback at the end of this
webinar through the pooling activity now
let me to come and provide you as
introduction to our trainer Bernard I'm
proud to introduce Bernard as a guru who
will conduct this webinar as I said my
cloud computing makes DevOps inevitable
named by Viacom he's one of the 10 most
influential person in cloud computing
and Bernard golden is CEO of company
Novica a consulting firm focused on
cloud computing and DevOps if means guys
that we have really guru on today's
session Bernd also serves as the cloud
computing and the miser for seem to
learn the leading online training search
vacation has seemed to learn advisor he
provides guidance on cloud computing
adoption trance training needs and
critical development as well as serving
the public face of simpler cloud
training offerings and he's chief
examiner for the APM G cloud computing
foundation certification used to certify
students across the globe and now I
would like to do the handover to burn
our golden and and the end of this ad we
will have a 15 minutes
question-and-answer time in the 15
minutes Q&A time we'll cover as many
questions as we can that weren't totally
covered during the session if you hear
something gave some brilliant
interesting insightful and you want to
share in your social channel whatever
your social channels are as a Facebook
LinkedIn Twitter you can use the hashtag
as well webinars that way people can
find it that you will make them be they
were here and you didn't come guys here
to listen to me and I'm proud through
the hand over to Bernard who will be
your host on today's session why cloud
computing makes DevOps inevitable go
ahead and sit back relax have a cup of
coffee tea or if it's evening Margaret
maybe a glass of wine and enjoy guys
thank you to all of you and happy seem
to learning hello Bernard
are you there yes hello Martin thank you
so much for that introduction and thank
you very much for inviting me to speak
today why don't we jump right into it
why cloud computing makes DevOps
inevitable and that let's start with the
state of the computing industry where is
computing being done and what does that
imply about what IT organizations are
going to do with their computing going
forward well in October Amazon announced
their AWS numbers the Amazon Web
Services numbers they are at a quarterly
rate of 3.2 billion dollars at a 56
percent growth rate so annualized that
comes to something like 13 billion
dollars growing 50
and ich per year that means next year
it's likely to be something like twenty
billion dollars just a week prior
Microsoft estimated its numbers for its
Azure offering and it's a little
difficult to figure out exactly what
those numbers are because they lump them
in with other service offerings like
office 365 but analysts estimate that
they're at about a 500 million to about
a 1 billion dollar run rate per quarter
for Azure but growing extremely rapidly
120 percent growth by the way Microsoft
announced its numbers for the fourth
quarter of 2016 just a few days ago and
again it was hard to figure out what the
numbers were because they were lumped in
with all these other services but they
announced that they were continuing to
grow higher at over a hundred percent
growth rate and just by way of
comparison to the rest of the industry
to give a sense of the of the magnitude
of how these cloud providers are growing
VMware which is a very well established
well-known enterprise software company
in that same quarter did about 1.7
billion dollars and about 6 percent
growth so if you look at it Amazon is
growing about 10 times as fast as VMware
it's nearly twice as large growing 10
times as fast and Microsoft while not
quite as large as VMware is growing at
something like 20 times the rate so that
gives you a sense of what's going on in
the industry in terms of the growth of
we're computing is being accomplished or
we're computing is being executed now if
we look at what this is going to look
like over time we're in 2017 now and
these numbers annualized for the to
providers Amazon and ashur will come to
something like over 20 billion dollars
but if you extrapolate their growth
rates around 50 percent and around a
hundred percent over the next three
years plus the remainder of 2017 it
means that Amazon and Azure
we'll be running almost a hundred
billion dollars a year of computing that
it represents an enormous footprint of
the processing power in the industry and
we can get a sense of what this means
for enterprise IT organizations by
looking at a survey that JP Morgan did
JP Morgan and this is from a business
investment perspective so this is the
investment arm JP Morgan which is trying
to understand what's going to go on in
the computing industry as a result of
cloud computing so they went out and did
a survey of 200 large enterprise CIOs
the average IT spend that these CIOs
represented was around 600 million
dollars per year now that varied so for
some of them it was 20 or 30 million
dollars and some of them it was several
billion dollars but average it was about
600 million dollars which is a very
large amount of IT spend and they said
the question they asked them was what
percentage of your applications
currently run in public cloud
environments and what percentage will
you be doing in 2020 and the answer came
back that it was going to represent a
dramatic growth in cloud adoption over
the near future today to 2016 about 16%
of enterprise applications were deployed
in public cloud environments but in four
years 2020 it was gonna represent about
41% of all application deployment so in
other words going on half of all
enterprise applications we're going to
be running in these cloud environments
now they didn't ask the question what
about after 2020 is it going to stop and
plateau at 41% or does that 41% just
represent a station on the way to 50%
70% whatever it might be but what we can
take from this is that for mainstream
enterprises cloud computing is going to
rip is going to become a very large
proportion of
of the computing footprint and that in
turn carries dramatic implications and
that's what we're talking about today
let's understand the difference between
old infrastructure and cloud
infrastructure to really recognize how
dramatic the differences are in the old
infrastructure you had to get capital
investment up front typically that meant
you had to go request budget make a
large investment a large purchase and
then you installed it it could take
months to availability depending on the
budgetary cycle how long it took to
order the equipment when it arrived how
quickly it could be installed and
configured and so forth so from the
point of view of time where you said we
need to do some kind of computing it
could be months before you'd actually be
ready to start executing something it
was quite static typically you'd install
it
you'd say it's never going to change it
would be very difficult to change and so
it was very hard if something changed
about your application to change the
environment that it was executing in it
was hard to scale if your application
blew up and got five times the traffic
you expected you were in a world of hurt
because to get more equipment to support
that load you were back through the
upfront capital investment budgetary
cycle etc typically these were managed
by heavy processes ITIL is the kind of
the classic example of what this would
be and you know change Control board's
if you want to make some kind of an
update to the application had to go
through a a process of approvals maybe
that was done every couple of weeks
something like that really difficult to
be responsive to the market and of
course it was run all by manual
operation so you want to make some
change and you got your change requests
approved you then submitted a trouble
ticket someone put it onto a queue and
eventually got worked on and that could
be part of a long time frame lengthy
delay card infrastructure changes this
completely there's low inventor initial
investment I mean you can start and just
be paying pennies per hour to start
computing and that means you don't have
to go through all of that budgetary
cycle you don't have to get large
approvals you can start
computing immediately because it's
minutes to availability you request
resources from someplace like Amazon or
Asher and literally within 10 minutes
they're there and it actually it could
be a lot faster than that today you can
actually go into Amazon or as you're
cold you don't even have an account and
within 10 minutes have an account and
have computing resources up and running
those resources are dynamic so it's very
easy to change them you can take
resources down add new resources and so
forth and it's quite easy because they
are running to be dynamic it's trivial
to scale you want to add more computing
resources to an application to handle
unexpected load again it's available in
minutes
it's like process friendly which means
that you don't have to overload this
very difficult kind of resource
availability with manual processes that
are signed to slow down making changes
and then of course this automated
operation
you know you issue an API call or
something like that and it happens in
the background no one has to touch the
equipment no one has to make any
particular hands-on visit into the data
center really quite dramatic difference
in the way that infrastructure is
managed so what does that mean for
DevOps well let's talk about the great
sage of the Brassica Warren Buffett one
of the greatest investors of all time
and he has a saying where he says only
when the tide goes out do you discover
who's been swimming naked and he is
usually applying that in a an investing
context which means you may have a
business that looks great when times are
good in the economy is booming but only
when times get tough do you find out
who's got a sustainable business
offering so only when one thing that
you've assumed changes do you see what's
going on underneath the covers or
underneath the water and I
that's a very instructive Maxim for
cloud computing because the tech version
of Buffett is removing one bottleneck
exposes the next bottle EXO in his case
removing that opaqueness of the water
shows you who is not who does not have
sufficient safety in place if there's
not water they're protecting the view
within tech once you remove one
bottleneck it inevitably shows you the
next constraint in the system so
removing one bottleneck exposes the next
one and to apply this Maxim in our space
now that deployment speed is no longer
the primary bottleneck application
development and deployment speed is now
the primary bottleneck so we've removed
all of that friction that used to be in
present when you had to get resources
computing resources available once
that's gone the next thing that slows
down being able to be responsive around
IT is how fast can you develop and
deploy applications and that is a
critical factor for IT in a way
organizations IT organizations have been
used to have an excuse around getting
things done quickly because they say
well it's gonna take forever to get our
resources so if you weren't very good at
application development you weren't very
fast you weren't very sophisticated
about the way you deployed applications
it kind of didn't matter because it was
all overshadowed by the length of time
that it took to really run
infrastructure now that that's no longer
the case it exposes the challenges
around application development and
deployment and that's what makes DevOps
inaudible inevitable inevitable
inevitable going forward that is the
reason that cloud computing makes DevOps
inevitable because now you have to focus
on make sure that your applications
development employment goes faster
so how do we go about addressing
application publics well we have to look
at all phases of the application process
the application lifecycle you might call
it so from a business driver business
organizations business units they want
to accelerate innovation they want to be
able to bring new products and services
into the market faster so they want to
be able to collaborate with IT to
rapidly develop and deploy new offerings
they want to be able to do frequent
releases to offer new functionality very
quickly to to send out more frequent
smaller updates more functionality
improvements more quickly they don't
want to be stuck in the way that things
have used to be which was because it was
so hard to get resources so hard to get
things deployed you tend to have big
bang releases very large collaborations
of functionality with this new world
they don't want to do that they want to
be able to bleed out new and incremental
functionality to users when that
functionality is available and that
makes it easier for users to adopt as
well because they're not being faced
with gigantic changes when they get new
functionality and they want continuous
integration they need to have the
ability to provide new functionality
expose new back-end features new
transaction types so forth and so on so
they need continuous iteration turning
to DevOps you want to be able to
increase throughput so now you've got
good ability to develop applications to
have tight collaboration between
business and IT to develop new
functionality to do frequent releases
now you want to be able to get them out
into infrastructure you won't be able to
deploy them quickly you don't want to be
turning them over to somebody who says
well I've got to do a rebuild I've got
to go do a create a new red book etc etc
you want to be able to increase
throughput you need automated operations
so a code change can be shifted into
production with no one having to touch
it with no one having to run new
processes with no manual handover you
want continuous deployment so that a
change what's improved
production can be deployed in a matter
of minutes and then of course you need
distributed monitoring and management
this is a world where again resources
are quite dynamic they're joining and
leaving the application pool all the
time you need monitoring and management
that are very flexible that can accept
new resources joining the application
pool start monitoring them start
tracking make sure they're operating
properly start throwing off logs from
them and so forth and you need that to
be able to handle a distributed
application topology so that sort of
says I've got all the capabilities
around fast development at fast
deployment that needs to go into a cloud
computing environment which helps you to
boost efficiency so infrastructure
availability obviously it doesn't do you
any good if you develop very quickly
you're ready to employ the the system
and then you're back to that old world
of infrastructure where it took months
to get resources available so you need
infrastructure availability in a course
of minutes you need scaling elasticity
and resilience to be in place because
again these kinds of applications are
turning from traditional back office
applications which need a good
availability but if they were down for a
while it just inconvenienced employees
these are now turning to the primary
turning into the primary way that
organizations operate with their
customers the primary way that users
interface with companies they have to be
available 24 by 7 and so you need
resilience built into the application so
that they can be remain available in the
in the face of a resource failure or
even a data center going down so you
need scaling elasticity resilience and
you need cost-effectiveness that's very
very important because these are now
part of the cost of goods sold these
applications you know you might be
putting out a product the example I use
a lot is a Withings scale whiffing scale
is a scale that is made by a french
company that not only tells your weight
but it also tells your body fat
percentage
your heart rate and so forth it has an
app that it talks to so that you have a
track over time of what your weight
trends have been and so forth
but it also has capabilities of being
connected into your social media and you
know you might say why would you want to
have your scale broadcast what your
weight is but for many people who are in
a weight loss regimen where they're
trying to lose weight having a peer
group that can support them and can say
oh I saw that you lost half a pound you
want me to go is varied is a very strong
motivating factor and so with things has
built that into their scale so they've
got a lot of computing behind this scale
and for Withings they sell the scale for
150 bucks or something like that they've
got to know that over the lifetime of
that scale that not only can they
support the price of this of the
components of the scale but also the all
of the computing back-end as well so
they need a cost effective computing
back-end for that for that device they
need that application to be cost
effective so that they can run make
these scales at a profit and run them
over their lifespan which might be 10 or
15 years so you need a cloud computing
environment to be able to do that and
then all of that the ability to develop
quickly to release more frequently to
run it in an efficient very scalable
environment that really changes the
dynamics of business itself so it
enables experimentation when you're a
business unit representative like a
product manager or something you can say
you know it'd be interesting to see a
tweak on our product if we offered you
know some new functionality or a new
report I mean where things might say you
know why don't we do something where we
share this with your doctor and put out
a fuzz formatted report that shows
information relevant to your doctor
let's try that out and this whole
application lifecycle that you've
accelerated supports fast prototyping
they could put that up try it with say
50 doctors and 100 user
and see how that's you see if it helps
make medical appointments more
informative or at least some better
outcomes or makes patients happier you
can do market trials extended into new
regions very easily and you can do fast
follow-on oh that thing with the doctors
and the users of patients worked really
well let's roll it out to ten thousand
users and their doctors and see how it
goes so it enables fast follow-on so
this is kind of a virtuous cycle that
getting all of this right really helps
improve business outcomes and again if
you just have the cloud computing part
of it without the agile and DevOps piece
you're really not improving things
because even though you're really fast
with infrastructure you're really slow
with the application so that's why
DevOps becomes inevitable in this world
so where does that leave us
[Music]
well DevOps means automation right and
it does but it requires the right kind
of automation on the left is the
original assembly-line Henry Ford's
assembly line and they're building this
but it was really a matter of putting
work in front of workers who still
perform manual tasks and so it was much
more efficient than what had been
present in that previously but it still
required a lot of manual intervention on
the right is today's assembly line and
you can see that for this portion of the
assembly there are no humans present
performing this work there's no one
welding panels it's all being done by
robots and that's really the vision of
what DevOps is it's not bringing
automatically bringing work to people
who then perform manual tasks it is
figuring out how those tasks can be
automated themselves and placed into
that are executed dynamically
automatically by a change of a status by
an event being triggered
so DevOps does mean automation but it
means how do we have automation all the
way through the lifecycle so that no one
has to touch it what we're trying to
avoid is what I call silo automation and
manual handles and this is where you've
got a situation where for example
someone in the Operations Group the
infrastructure group has written scripts
to automatically create virtual machines
which is great but the trigger for a
needing a new virtual machine is maybe
someone says I'm ready to roll out a new
test version of my application and I
need to run some stress tests on it my
code is ready and the person says I'll
trigger off this script to put up my
virtual machine ok the virtual machines
ready now point me to where the code is
so I can go manually install it you've
got a silo automation there one group
has automated their tasks but you have
an automated inter organization you have
an automated the entire process and
that's a common problem you get groups
saying I'm gonna make my work more
efficient but without any sense from the
organization itself of how do we
streamline the entire process and so you
get this kind of herky-jerky
start and stop oh yeah I my parts all
done now I'm waiting for the next group
to take the handoff and that might even
be triggered by trouble ticket see
you're back to that old trouble ticket
driven model that's not super helpful
the model that we really want to look at
is intergroup automation how do we get
each group able to hand its piece off to
someone else that is already prepared
and uh nota mated acceptance and
execution of their processes and then an
automated head off to the next one so
how do you go from where development
finishes a code change it automatically
flows through to a QA process where
there are tests that are automatically
executed and once those have
successfully
past it moves on to staging where
additional testing might be done or
integration testing might be done once
that's passed and that's done all
automatically it flows through two auto
operations which has the ability to
automatically trigger changes into a
dynamic infrastructure so the motion is
you really want this kind of bucket
brigade where things flow automatically
that's the solution that we want to look
at so the DevOps journey is really a
three phase process analysis
implementation and then operation once
you've got the system in place so
analysis is identify your
forward-looking infrastructure where are
you going to be placing applications and
as we saw earlier in this webinar
increasingly that's going to be a
cloud-based environment and then go
through a process called value chain
definition and I'm going to talk about
value chains next slide
but in other words what are all of the
steps that we go through from someone's
making a code change in our application
to it actually up and running and
someone able to access it some user
being able to access it implementation
is okay we know what we want to do how
do we do it we identify our automation
tools we map the inputs and outputs of
each of those tools we select and design
the tools that we're going to use to
glue those automation tools together and
then we test and move into production we
test the system to make sure it's kind
of going to work and then we start using
it for real-world use and then within
operation we want to have the ability to
do very flexible kinds of deployments
canary a be testing incremental growth
deployment I'll have to find these a
little more in a few slides and then
implementing roll back function now the
traditional model of IT was you made a
change you rolled out and you assumed
everything was going to go well well
guess what
everything doesn't always go well does
it but we didn't really have a very good
ability to say oh that didn't work let's
go back to where things were in the
previous state in fact for most
organizations to back out of change was
a manual intervention that there
very good guidelines for and so it's
almost like a real-time firefighting
experiment and very challenging often
led to extended outages we don't want
that so we want to have the ability to
do automated rollback functionality so
analysis selects your future
infrastructure choices you know what
cloud environments are we going to be
using what functionality within those
cloud environments are we going to be
taking advantage of how are we going to
be able to use those services this is
the services that we're going to be
needing and these are the KPIs and and
interfaces by which we access those
services so we need to be able to
automate being able to deploy into and
run in those services what are the
automation tools that we're going to be
using we're gonna be using chef or
puppet or ansible or maybe we're going
to be using Jenkins as a way to take
code changes and then call testing and
so forth you know figure out what are
the right tools for us and you know I
always say it's good to take those and
do an analysis and choose one through a
deliberate process think that the whole
organization that participates in
oftentimes these kinds of DevOps things
are done as skunkworks operations where
someone makes a choice based on you know
tool they used it their last job or
something that they've heard is really
good or they just want to try something
new to learn new skills all that's very
admirable but the problem is you end up
then with one group has their DevOps
tool chain done with this set of tools
another group has a different set of
tools in their tool chain and that's a
recipe for problems because you know
applications then it will have to be
managed differently it's very difficult
to transfer people across groups because
they have to learn entire new skills and
so forth it tends to impose high
operational costs through the overall
organization so you know my
recommendation our recommendation is to
identify and select automation tools
that can be that should be used across
the organization this can be challenging
requires more planning upfront but it
pays tremendous benefits downstream as
you get efficiency across the entire
application lifecycle mapping the inputs
and outputs you're using chef you know
what are what are the calls that you
make to deploy a new server or a new
container likewise we're using puppet
what are those calls that you make and
what are calls that you can then can
make into the configuration management
system to pull code out and install it
into that new virtual machine in that
new container you need to have an
understanding of all those inputs
outputs because you want to get to a
place where you automate the calls
through those inputs output so you don't
need to understand them so you need to
map them so if I'm putting making calls
into Chef and it executes what are the
outputs that it will put out that I need
to then pass on to the next the next
part that part of the process what kind
of objects will hand out what kinds of
event triggers will it put out and so
forth
so that you can then map those as an
input into the next step of the process
selecting design integration tools you
know and that those need to work across
public cloud and internal infrastructure
hopefully you'll get tools that can map
across both of those you know it's not
that convenient to have two different
kinds of sets of tooling it may be
unavoidable are you gonna be using
virtual machines or containers again
that will change the tooling that you
can use because some tools are great for
virtual machines some are identified as
being appropriate for containers others
try and map across both you need to make
a decision about that and of course it
depends on what you are overall
direction is our container is going to
become a big part of your computing
environment well you need to plan for
that as well and really coming up for
many IT organizations are serverless
type environments where use also call
functions as a sir
you need to think about how are you
gonna deploy those code fragments and
then some sort of an orchestration
framework you know kubernetes is one
that's quite popular for containers
you know virtual machines you might use
either a third-party tool or you might
be using something like elastic
beanstalk from Amazon you need to figure
out what the orchestration framework is
because that's what's going to be
managing and monitoring the the
application deployment environment and
in terms of the value chain definition
the value chain is a very important part
of the process many IT organizations
rely on kind of tacit knowledge someone
joins an Operations groups and get and
gets told this is where you go to get
your code or this is how you implement
this is how you deploy code or this is
you who you go request something from
and it's all very undocumented it's all
very unknown it's not even necessarily
known if it's prickly efficient it may
just be the way that something happened
three years ago because when particular
operations in here said you know I'd
like it done this way and that spread
through the operations group and then
spread upstream to other groups it may
not be efficient it may have extra steps
it may be imposing bottlenecks because
it all has to flow through one person
who was the person who you know approves
worker who whatever it might be so the
value chain definition is you go through
and say what are all the steps in the
current path from development its
deployment who is everyone that touches
this code change what do they do you
identify the necessary and unnecessary
ones so you know are things that we're
doing that really don't help this
process
do we have a local CMDB and then the
corporate CMDB you probably don't need
to you shouldn't have to so maybe one of
those needs to be removed so that might
become unnecessary
so select necessary and unnecessary
going forward you say we've got to
incorporate all the necessary ones and
we've got a plan to obsolete all of the
unnecessary ones let's get them out of
our process because just extra work it's
not very efficient it requires
additional maintenance of integration
and so forth and if it doesn't help
let's get rid of it group and ungroup
you might be able to say you know these
two current separate steps could be
combined into one thing with the tool
that we're gonna use let's group those
let's accomplish them all in one step
and then define the inputs and outputs
and I've talked about the API is the
events and the objects and so forth
that's what you're gonna be looking at
defining all that the value chain coming
out of that you say here are all the
steps that are necessary here's all the
inputs and outputs from those various
steps according to the tools that we
selected okay now we know what we need
to build for our DevOps
tool chain our DevOps flow let's go
ahead and implement that you've
identified the automation tools um some
might be partially partly dictated
depending on you know what environment
you're using or other tools that you've
got and partly chosen ideally you'd like
to find tools that are already
integrated or already have pre-built
integrations with the tools on either
side of them so in other words instead
of you having to take on the
responsibility for building that
integration wouldn't it be great if the
tool you choose already has integration
built for then the tools that it's going
to have to integrate with and this is
you know Jenkins for example has many
many pre-built integrations so when you
decide to have it connect to selenium
for unit testing it's already got
integration you stop to configure that
integration but you're not having to
write code to get information from one
tool to another
seek tools with pre-built integrations
look for large ecosystems you know going
back to Jenkins very large ecosystem
lots of people who use it there's lots
of use cases being put forward into the
people who build it so it's it's like
it's a rich execution environment it's
got lots of functionality it's validated
by many many organizations using it it's
easy to find skills out in the
marketplace if you need to hire people
in to run that so it's very it reduces
the friction to adoption so look for
large ecosystems avoid premature
enthusiasm don't you know install a tool
say wow it looks really great that's
what we're gonna do going forward be
deliberate about this and you know make
sure you understand what you're getting
yourself in for you know map the inputs
and outputs we've talked about that each
tool must receive send automated data
event triggers of logging logging is
extremely important in this world
because if something doesn't go well you
want to be able to identify where did it
fail what caused it to fail oftentimes
you have to do root cause analysis
because what it appears is the symptom
of the failure is not the actual cause
of the problem you'll need to go back
through logs to identify where did the
the first failure occur and what tool or
what process or what part of the code
did that and ensure that you've got
input output mapping alignment you know
this is sort of the famous you want to
make sure that what the downstream tool
requires the upstream tool can spit out
select or design your integration tools
you want tools that can be easily
integrated with automation tools you
want tools that support common data
formats support common types of calls
and so forth what's really important
about this is to recognize that your
DevOps tool chain is now an application
itself and it requires maintenance and
investment there you're gonna have to
have people who are experts in this who
run the this who makes sure that it's
maintained that if you have a particular
tool in the tool chain and it's updated
that you have a way of taking that new
version of this tool that you're using
validate it make sure that it operates
make sure the integrations still operate
correctly and so
so they're gonna have to have their own
set of people their own set of
environments where they can perform
tests that they can make code changes to
the tools or the integrations themselves
valid if they still work validate they
can scale so this is now a new
application that you need to maintain
and need to recognize that it will
require an ongoing budget and investment
as long as you're using it so you know
the the the flipside of this great new
automated system is it's an application
itself and you need to be able to devote
resources to maintain it and don't make
the mistake of saying well we got it
built let's pull all the people off of
it and you know it'll work automatically
forever going forward no application
does and this is this application this
DevOps tool chain is no different test
and moving and production validate with
segregated application soap start with a
single application start with an
application that doesn't have a lot of
other integrations that depend on it
train the affected personnel you know
people who used to do things manually
they're not going to be doing them
automatically or if they're going to be
using a new tool to perform their their
their function make sure they know how
to use it make sure they're got they're
capable with it you don't want to do a a
cold switch to a new tool and then have
people go god I don't really understand
it it's not working properly and I don't
really know what's going on with it I'd
better start you know going online and
googling problems that is not a good
that's not a good situation you want to
require it for new applications so all
new applications are done the new way no
exceptions and if somebody says well you
know it's a new application but I'm more
comfortable doing it the old way I think
I'll do it that way no because that's
just gonna mire you in more of the old
way of doing things more of the slow
bottleneck that you've had in place know
you want to require it for new
applications and then you know for
existing applications that have
significant ongoing maintenance activity
it's a very viable strategy say you know
this is an application that only has
trivial changes every year why make that
investment to automate all of that if
it's if it if it's so infrequently
changed I wouldn't do that so but if
you've got applications that are and
have significant ongoing maintenance
they're getting new updates frequently
that they require new changes because of
business reasons legal reasons whatever
it might be it makes sense to go back
and invest in them to bring them up to
this new automated system because
they're going to be an ongoing set of
changes they face the bottleneck of
application development employment make
the investment to ease their ability to
to move to this new environment
operation well low friction deployment
will be accompanied by some percentage
of poor deployments what does that mean
well once it gets easier to do something
you're gonna do more of it and you're
gonna have some percentage that aren't
that aren't good deployments I mean
you're doing you're gonna encourage
experimentation well guess what not all
experiments work not all experiments pan
out you want to fail fast you want to
put it out there learn from it and if it
goes well you wanna be able to put the
pedal to the metal if it doesn't you
wanna be able to fail fast and say you
know that was a that was an honorable
try but it didn't work let's pull it out
and you want to reduce the cost of
failure so you want to encourage
business experimentation because that's
the new world we're in so you're gonna
have some percentage of poor deployments
you just need to understand that and
recognize that and understand that
you're going to be in a situation where
you have to back changes out so agile
operations is a two-way street
there's deployment and rollback and
unless rollback is easy and cheap DevOps
is incomplete meaning if you're really
good at deploying changes but if
something needs didn't work and you need
to back it out you're back to the old oh
we're in a we're in a fire drill let's
call everyone up they've got to come in
they've got to start
figuring out what code changes were made
figure out manual interventions that's a
big problem so you need to have the
ability to just as you want to be able
to press a button to deploy something
you're gonna be able to press a button
to underplay and the deployment patterns
you want to support canary canary is the
next you know comes from canary in a
coal mine you put something out there to
see how it works so you might deploy a
code change into just one machine to
make sure that it really works in your
operations vironment so a canary
deployment is we're gonna put it out
there and see if it stands up and works
properly a beat is you know we're gonna
put it out to some proportion of our
users and see what the adoption is for
example you know Netflix does this all
the time they'll make a small change to
their user interface to see if it
increases engagement increases the total
minutes viewed and so forth and they'll
put it out to say you know 5,000 users
and and let another 5,000 continue the
way things have been and then look at
the relevant stats for those for that
pool of 10,000 and say oh the new change
actually reduced the number of minutes
that people use so it's not a good
change so you're doing testing so you
want an appointment pattern that can say
you know make this available to the next
5,000 people who come in or spread the
next 10,000 people across these two
options so that we can validate the
statistics incremental growth deployment
is you know I mean Netflix is a good
example of that you know we you know we
added a million new viewers we need more
in computing resources in our
application so supporting incremental
growth you know we need another 10%
execution environment up and running and
it needs to be joined in our pool and so
forth your operations your DevOps needs
to be able to support that Bluegreen
which is a model that says when we put
out a major code change we actually
stand it up on mirrored infrastructure
make sure it's up and running properly
and then redirect our DNS to the new
environment
so we go from blue which is a the
version say 1.2 to green which is 1.3 at
one point we have both of them up and
running but all traffic is going to the
blue deployment we make that change we
flipped the DNS and also the traffic all
shifts or to green
you wanted a operations environment that
can support that and this is typically
accompanied by application analytics you
know soar
you know netflix is gonna be looking at
you know the relevant stats what was the
total time of engagement did people
click on certain kinds of shows more so
forth sort so you've got application
analytics to backup not backup but to
figure out did those changes that we've
made make sense should we roll them out
to the rest of the application pool or
should we back them out and then
implementing rollback functionality you
want to be able to a ability to restore
it to pre deployment status so yank out
all those changes it brings confidence
in bullets what do I mean by that well
it means that if you're if you know that
you can put a change out and then pull
it back if it if it doesn't work or
turns out to be non useful that makes
you more courageous that makes you more
willing to experiment that makes you
more likely to put changes out there
typically the one got you are on that is
storage schemas because it's once you
put out a storage schema it's very
difficult to change it back it can be
quite difficult so you've got to be very
careful around your storage schemas so
that you've got the ability to take
those new fields that you needed for the
new functionality and still leave them
there even though that may be they're
not being used if you do a rollback
[Music]
so in conclusion after cloud the
application ploy cycles of primary
Moloch and many IT organizations will
confront this as they start to adopt
cloud because what's gonna happen is
business users say oh you started using
the cloud that's so fantastic resources
are available so fast it's so great you
know you can it's very elastic and all
that how come it still takes us weeks to
get code changes put into production why
is that then it's going to become clear
that the application lifecycle is a
primary bar like DevOps is a journey
with iteration you're not gonna get it
right the first time you're gonna find
incremental improvement so you could
make figure on that you want to do both
intra and Inter task automation you
don't want to end up with automated
silos you know you want to reduce the
cost of deployment how much work it is
to make a change to make a code change
to accelerate change to enable business
experimentation and reduce the cost to
rollback to encourage experimentation
all right well Martin that is our
webinar that is the material do we have
questions that have been put forward
that we can address okay Bernina it was
really great I just follow up where
attendees and try to recognize their
questions unfortunately they don't have
a question but now let me to open our
polls activity and after that I will try
to ask you an example question by my
side or you should go and make some
summary about today's webinar it's up to
you but let's say that we have last
eight minutes and I would like to open
this activity and after that well we
will decide what they gonna do okay
you should make summary or I will ask
you a question or something like that
okay okay now well I would like to ask
our attendees to to use this quick poll
activity and to provide these responses
to to us because as I said this is also
quite important and doing this pooling
activity I should say that it was really
really
presentation as a sadness is this is
first time that I'm with you were not on
cloud presentation and really enjoyable
and very very great information I I got
from you especially when you explain an
example Warren Buffett's lessons or when
you compare all the infrastructure but
it was cloud infrastructure very very
good things there and left me to go and
through the the question and our
attendees asked for for the presentation
as a material I think that we are not
able to share this presentation may read
our attendees this is a kind of rabiner
primarily concept for that is to show
tour attendees how to go and move to the
next step but this is a let's say key
that I would like to ask you burner
what's after let's say this webinar has
a question fooor from our us and this is
what they have to do after that to go
and register themselves to some sessions
with a training or could you explain
something about that so it would be
please
well I first I believe that the is
brought this webinar was recorded and
will be available for people to either
review or to share with other people
isn't that right Martin so that they all
have access to the material
this webinar so you know I this is a
this move to cloud and this move to
DevOps ISM is a big change for
organizations I've I've been you know
involved with many organizations going
through these process changes as they
move and it requires significant it
represents a very different way of doing
things and and just to kind of go back
to that auto assembly line I mean when
Henry Ford put together that assembly
line
you know previously the way people have
built cars was basically you know people
like you were like me or any of the
attendees we just have a big stack of
parts and they'd walk over and they'd
pick a part up and then they walk back
and attach it and everybody did
everything
and you know that that was not very
efficient the assembly line you know as
it was put into place really required
skill changes because people stopped
doing everything and started focusing on
I'm gonna be the person who you know
attaches the carburetor to the engine or
I'm gonna be the person who installs the
seats and it was a very different
skillset and you know the assembly line
itself really emphasizes that
incremental change that I was talking
about because it wasn't like Henry Ford
just put together that first assembly
line and that was it he tinkered with it
over over years to continue to improve
it to continue making it more efficient
to streamline the activities and he over
time made the process more and more and
more efficient and you know that's a
sort of a lesson for all of us is that
you know originally a Model T cost
around I think about 800 or $900 in
those days dollars which were a lot more
than 800 or $900 today but through the
process of all of this efficiency
continuing to tweak the assembly line
kits new make incremental improvements
he eventually got it down to about $250
$295 something like that so you know it
was one-third the cost and guess what
happened
lots more people bought cars so you know
volume went up and that's the kind of
thing that we'll see around this kind of
streamlining of the application
lifecycle people should expect that so
learning new skills is really critical
and you know the way it was done you
know five or eight or ten years ago was
somebody said I'm gonna go learn I'm
gonna go online I'm gonna go recent blog
post that that's inefficient and it
doesn't scale and you end up with
somebody saying I know how to do this
this way and I know how to do it this I
know and somebody else says I know how
to do this a different way you want
consistency for the reasons I outlined
so you know going through training
structured training that of the type
that simplement offers is is the best
way to go about making this change
within an organization making it
consistent and making it occur more
rapidly
okay thanks a lot Bernhard and I would
like just to come back to the question I
had referring to the next step it means
after does this webinar what is the next
step for our Anthony's as your
recommendation as a trainer and guru in
cloud stuff and so on well really it was
where I said you know identify a
particular application make sure that
you've got the skills in place to use
put that application into a cloud
environment and surround it with a
DevOps capability and really you know
that's requires making sure that your
people are educated and trained it up
the speed so choose the right
application make sure that you've got
the right skills in place through
training and then go ahead and execute
and use that as a learning experience so
you know not only do you do the
application but you make sure that you
draw out organizational learnings from
it that you can then spread throughout
the organization okay great Bernard and
because we don't have any other
questions left menow to to close our
pulling activity and let's say that we
should come to the final stage of our
webinars today we're running over let's
say the time schedule for more than
three four minutes and let's do this
summarize of that Kincaid that you want
otherwise we should go and close now
down this webinar it was really great
and enjoyable except especially for me
as your assistant or moderator and
please burner now just make a summary of
that and we should go and close this
webinar right so let me just conclude by
saying that cloud makes DevOps
inevitable that was the title of this
webinar and I think it really is the
theme that attendee should take away you
know you by taking advantage of cloud
computing which you will according to
what JP Morgan says you will be forced
to examine your internal
too late and that's gonna be an ongoing
investment you need skills and so forth
to accomplish that this will help you
and help your business become more
effective because they'll be able to
roll things into the marketplace more
quickly experiment launch new products
so forth and you want to be sure that
you've got full support from the
lifecycle meaning not only can you
develop and deploy quickly but you can
also roll back as well with that Martin
I think that we're concluded and maybe
you want to go ahead and and conclude
the webinar okay thanks a lot
Bernard it was really great as I said
many times now we are really at the end
of this great webinar related to the
cloud and I think that is pretty clear
why cloud computing makes DevOps in a
meatball as you made great explanation
about that and lets me to tell you good
morning or good afternoon or good night
depends where you are and this is hand
of this webinar thanks a lot
Bernard and good night
you